so Black Friday is just three days away
and lock the Black Friday deals I've
already been forecasted so if you're in
the market for new PC peripherals and
here are the best deals I can find first
up if you're looking for a new monitor
to go along with that new PC here's a
great 24 inch monitor from MSI the msi
optics maag 24 C is at 144 third one
millisecond response time 1080p monitor
it has a curved screen and it usually
costs $250 but this Black Friday you can
pick it up from 106 dollars so $90 off
if you spend just $20 more than that you
can actually pick up the msi optics maag
27 1c which is basically the same
monitor but Ashley has 27 inch of screen
space it is also curved has 144 Hertz
refresh rate 1 millisecond response time
additionally it also has a precinct and
it usually cost $300 so this is a bigger
Disgaea hundred $20 personally I would
go with a 27-inch variant because it is
a lot bigger discount and it's like
tomorrow is more than 24 inch monitor
anyways however I do understand a lot of
you guys think that 1080p is too low of
resolution for 27 inches so it really
comes down to personal preference but
both those monitors are great monitors
with really high refresh rates and low
response time totally great prices next
up if you're looking for a keyboard then
get the classic Corsair k70 for just $1
this Black Friday
usually it's MSRP is actually around 107
dollars bond Amazon you can probably get
it for 130 120 usually but now I can get
it for 80 so it's a very steep discount
over MSRP
the courser k95 also has a pretty good
discount at $140 and MSRP is $200 so $6
off but honestly I would just recommend
you go to k70 unless you have some
specific reason to go for the k95 like
the macro keys on the left side if
you're looking for Mouse's then you can
pick up the Logitech G 203 prodigy Mouse
for 25 bucks its MSRP is $40 and it says
6000 dpi Mouse it is a very nice clean
looking Mouse with nice ambient lighting
if you want some more sensitivity at
12,000 dpi you can pick up Logitech G
pro for just $5 more at $30 its MSR
seven dollars so it is being offered for
a very steep discount and finally if you
are on top of line Mouse you pick the
logitech g502 proteus spectrum mouse for
35 bucks so final is more its MSRP is a
dollar so it's also being offered for a
very steep discount personally though
I'd go up to Logitech G pro finally
there is one more Mouse the Corsair m65
pro RGB Mouse its MSRP is six dollars
and it was being offered for three
dollars but if that deal is now it's
expired and it's out of stock however it
may come back and stock a little bit
later so make sure keep an eye out for
that as well it is also a 12,000 dpi
Mouse and it's one of the most classic
Mouse's available and for the last thing
on this list is headsets and for this
we're starting off with the Corsair
worried RGB Pro headset which is usually
at $80 maybe pick it up right now for 50
bucks if you want some wireless
functionality on top of that you can
spend an additional $15 making it $65
and you can buy that of Corsair avoid
RGB profile as I've said which usually
cost $100 and if you don't want Corsair
avoid headsets you also pick up the
steel series of arctos 3 5 or 7 which
are all being offered for great
discounts at $50 $75 and $100
respectively those headsets usually cost
$8 $100 and a $150 so they all have a
pretty good discount on them but that's
pretty much it for this short video I
just want to go over the best peripheral
deals that I saw and I want to share it
with you guys so what do you guys think
about these deals do I miss something
big make sure to comment down below if I
miss any things with all the people can
benefit from it also if you guys like
this video make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing if you'd like to
see more videos just like this one
Vaughn till then I'm Ari
I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]